oh man no the red wedding was in three i
can't put that left
oh boy you know people will never
forgive me
do you have a strong opinion about what
happened with game of thrones jeremy
yeah yes i do have a strong opinion i
think it was amazing
i loved it i uh
i it's funny because i've just
re-watched it actually the entire thing
you know sarah my writing partner
producing partner were
huge fans um
and it's just excellent it's like it's
like nothing i've ever really seen on
television before and i thought the
the finale you know really especially on
a re-watch
was awesome and like i could actually
track i know a lot of people were upset
that
i think the controversy was the
character daenerys
wouldn't wouldn't um
wouldn't have have retaliated exactly
the way she did
but if you watch and because we just did
this
if you watch all the seasons back to
back you can really see her
her aggression was always there
but people were keeping her in check and
then finally she
just released it all um
so i thought it was great i i love game
of thrones
so the ending was was satisfying to the
two of you
the ending was completely satisfying for
us yeah we loved it
i know a lot of people had their
misgivings but i think if people
you know it's it's difficult because how
can you please
everybody who watched it and and people
loved it so much i loved it so much that
it's it's really hard to
i totally understand that i uh meet
everyone's
expectations but i think on the re-watch
it it really is even better
do you wish that george rr martin had
completed
all of the books beforehand did you
notice a difference in the writing style
so actually i'd never read any of the
books so
i don't know i've only been a fan of the
television series
and i always loved the writing in that i
do know that people
said i think some people i
knew had read some of the books but i've
actually never read any of them so
i'm still a fan
in the end do you think any mistakes
were made with the final season
you know i i do think
the final season obviously was so big i
mean
every episode was i think what 90
minutes long maybe
but um you know again just
it's all fresh in my mind because i just
i just saw them all but
you know i think every episode was just
so huge and and had so many you know
battle sequences and just just really
really big production stuff
you know i think there was what seven
episodes
and so maybe you know if they could have
had like maybe two or three more
episodes two more episodes
um maybe it would have helped people
feel
a little more um
[Music]
like like the character of daenerys had
had had a little bit more of an arc
which i think people were
reacting to um
[Music]
so you know i think i think they could
have done that but for the seven
episodes and for how big they were
and for just what a spectacle like they
were amazing
you know the battles and the the final
battle at winterfell there
it was like the best television i'd ever
seen
so i loved it i thought it was great and
now it totally satisfied me
so the first time the two of you watched
the entirety of the of the
different seasons when you went to
twitter
and you saw some of the outrage from the
fans
what was your thought i just thought you
know when i went to
after we had watched the finale
and we looked on twitter and saw people
were outraged i was a little
you know i was a little bit shocked
actually because it's just like
had been such an amazing show the entire
time and i just felt like people were
kind of like
um not taking all of that into
consideration
you know um but i think you know
again you it's it's it's impossible to
please everybody and it's impossible to
please everybody on twitter
you know the the uh the
outrage and and i thought it was just
excellent i think
i think people were overreacting and
again i think if people
watch it again and even watch the entire
series i think the
the signs and the clues to what they
were reacting against
were really always there um
and it's hard because you know game of
thrones there would be these huge
gaps between seasons i remember like
what was it like a year or a year and a
half even
um so it's you know that's a long time
and i think you maybe you
people would just you know maybe forget
or just um
you know just weren't remembering
exactly but if you watch them all back
to back
i think uh i think all the signs were
there
so if you keep with the theme of can't
please everybody of course
what is your thought of of when a fandom
has so much opinion
or or emotion over the outcome of what a
creator does or doesn't do
gosh it's so hard to say you know i
think
it it is interesting to see especially
in our world with social media
how like you know the the reactions of
the fans can
actually affect the final product of a
film i mean that's
we've never seen that before right like
not to my knowledge i don't think
there was ever anything in the past
where
you know the the public would have as
big of a voice
as they're having now because of all
this you know the twitter and facebook
and
whatever else um i
i don't know how to feel about it i mean
it's it's a very interesting thing where
it's like in some cases i think
it probably has helped and in some cases
i'm sure it's hurt
um but but i know like for instance
there was the
um the sonic the hedgehog movie
and like people were were
really criticizing the design of the
first character
and you know they modified it and
adjusted it and the second one and the
second one looked great
i thought so you know maybe that was a
good thing
and then i know there are uh
you know like there's also the outrage
of like a show like game of thrones
where i thought it was
really excellent and i thought that it
had been such a
awesome you know viewing experience and
awesome
for an audience for like seven seasons
and then people were just upset and i
just like
i don't know i i don't think sometimes
people are taking into consideration
everything that came before it and
they're just reacting on
you know literally what they saw an hour
ago
jeremy is there any way you could rank
the seasons of game of thrones from
let's say the
best season to the worst season sure so
if i had to rank
the game of thrones seasons highest to
lowest um
and i'm a fan of them all i would start
with
season six which i believe had
the battle of the bastards and daenerys
crossing this the the narrow sea
at the end of the season so six would be
my highest
probably seven and then probably
eight because i do like towards the end
there where everything was really
ramping up
and uh the stories were kind of tying up
and so like
you know there was there was a lot of
consequences a lot of stakes for
everybody i mean there was
there was a lot going on so i think
those three six
top then seven then eight
and then i mean i like them all
you know five i think is where jon snow
got killed so
i really like five so i think six
seven eight five
one two three
because i gotta go with one since like
that's
what kicked everything off so that
that'll go up there
so yes six seven eight
five one two oh wait i missed five
six seven eight five
four one two three that's my ranking
so the sixth season sixth season is your
favorite
yeah i'll do six season at the top okay
then season seven then season eight
then season five season
four and then season one
two and three and why three
if you had to choose your least why is
it last
one oh yeah we can give me a second okay
i'm sort of guessing on those last lines
oh no okay
i don't want to wait wait let me see let
me see well
the fourth one let me see oathbreaker
these are all great
i don't know man season three is pretty
good too
oh man no the red wedding was in three i
can't put that left
oh boy you know people will never
forgive me
yeah that's very really funny i can't do
that
so uh okay so my ranking would be season
six at the top season seven
season eight season
five season four season three
season one and then season two at the
bottom
so two was the least favorite i think
two would be my
least favorite although i still totally
enjoyed it um
maybe because things were still
getting going you know i gotta put one
up there because that's really what
kicked off the entire season
or the entire series i should say and
then um
yeah so maybe maybe season two would be
my least favorite
but i still love them all big fan so
even though you'd never read the books
the the series started you heard word of
mouth
what was about the world the world
building that you loved
yeah it's interesting like we when we
started watching it i
i hadn't ever read the books
i just think it was very unique of
course it was like
i think that's that's what i really
seized on maybe like there were
like you know sort of like things like a
medieval mythology like dragons and
i think those things were like alluded
to but like
there were still things about it that
like it just felt new
to me like um
you know there were obviously like
characters not behaving in ways that
i've
sort of had seen before um
you know they were kind of like you know
really like
sort of like kind of like mature themes
in this sort of that
in this sort of like um like a medieval
show
or like that sort of had those elements
but there was like
very mature themes in it which i was
like whoa like i haven't i don't think i
had seen that before
um and yeah like a lot of the characters
seemed very fresh
very new i thought again all of the the
dialogue was really like
really like layered and really complex
but also at times could be really like
kind of funny kind of sharply funny or
like humorous
um so it just felt like really like
fresh something like really that i
i felt like i'd never seen anything that
tackled it quite like that
you